I told him give it back to me so I can
have it for the shoot the drink I
promised once I'm done with GQ is coming
right back to you
hi my name is Jason or alphadon I'm CEO
of Jason of Beverly Hills we are the
go-to jeweler for some of the world's
biggest celebrities athletes socialites
royalty
this is GQ on the rocks I've always made
very crazy over-the-top pieces and I've
had a lot of clients that have made
ridiculous requests listen we've done
diamond door plates or Michael Jackson
hangers alive I had a request from a
client to do a diamond fish tank that we
did we had a key request from a client
that asked for a huge Jesus head but
instead of Jesus wanted to have his own
face in there that one I had to say no
to it's sacrilegious I'm not going to do
it the two things that I love are being
creative and meeting new people and I
picked the best job in the world because
I get to do both sometimes we have
different celebrities that will come
bring their watch collection to us and
have us kind of put our touch to it and
this particular watch was a fitfully Ted
Drake owns and he brought it to us and
he says I just want to go crazy I want
to do something no one else has done he
said like what are some of the rarest
most expensive stones you can find and I
told them I said you know pinks and
blues are the rarest and definitely the
most expensive somebody like Drake when
he hears that no one else has it he's
gonna go for it so these are all natural
pink diamonds these are all from the
Argyle mine in Western Australia and
it's one of the only mines that produce
these colors of pink they go over half a
million dollars for just the diamonds
that particular mine is supposed to be
completely done in 2021 so naturally the
prices of Pink's have gone up
considerably
we actually have an operational lighter
ring 18 karat gold over 7 carats of
diamonds diamonds going all the way
around and guess what you could light
your cigarette your cigar whatever else
you want to smoke this is gonna be able
to take care of it this is made up of
about 17 different components that all
have to be put together match perfectly
in order for it to work the way it works
a lot of our pieces that we make I like
to make a very limited edition the worst
thing in the world you're walking down
the street and you see someone wearing
the exact same thing you're wearing this
particular piece we're only making five
and that's it I don't care if we have a
line out in front of our stores with
more people wanting it we really want to
limit production to five pieces
this particular piece here is twelve
thousand nine hundred and fifty dollars
lighting fluid included our diamond
locking key you have 18 karat gold with
flawless baguette diamonds and round
diamonds on the key the key actually
opens up the lock you take it out or
lock it back up probably not tsa
approved but who knows something like
this you're looking at about $35,000
this one's not too bad
but I got something for you that then
it's gonna have a nice hefty price tag
on it okay what I'm gonna show you here
is something very important something
very different something very rare that
you're not going to see many times in
your lifetime if at all one of my very
very wealthy overseas clients who
happens to be an oil family called me up
and said I see all these rings you're
making for these different celebrities
but I want to do something that just
completely demolishes anything you've
done before so we went and we sourced
one particular stone fitting of that the
only one in the world with these exact
specs a 30 carat
diamon there is only one this is a one
of one there is no other but this
particular client demanded that of me
this is over five million dollars in
this single stone we're gonna be using
this stone to build the most insane
out-of-this-world mens pinkie ring in
the history of men's pinkie rings we are
actually taking this ring out and much
like many of our things we went through
an entire design process we are
finishing it up now this stone will be
placed in the ring next week and I'll be
flying overseas to go make the delivery
our team is designing it on the computer
right now so you guys can see that
because it's super dope let's go check
out the design I want to show you how it
looks so over here we're doing a 3d
rendering where we're laying out all the
stones how they're gonna be arranged and
we're laying it out over here so that we
get the realist picture image of what
the final product is gonna look like but
what makes this ring so unique is the
message that he has on the side to
everyone his ring says [ __ ] you money
and listen if you're gonna spend six
million dollars on a single ring I guess
you could write whatever it is that you
want to write so these are also men's
pinkie rings that are a little bit
different this one you have a six carat
fancy yellow with all pear shapes going
down 18 karat gold six carat yellow gie
certified something like this you're
looking around $300,000 over here we had
a client that reached out to us he
wanted to make a ring that kind of
resembled the outline of downtown LA and
the streets and the map and really love
the mosaic setting that we did so we
kind of designed this ring frame which
has diamonds going all the way around 18
karat yellow gold all flawless diamonds
with baguettes and hasher cuts and
princess cuts and rounds going around
the entire shank
I really enjoy Astra cuts I feel like
those are my favorite right now just
because there's not that many people
using them and we actually employed
those particular cuts in the large OBO
Owl for Drake and that's why he loved it
so much because he wanted to have
something that didn't have the same kind
of diamonds that everyone else is using
I was blessed enough in 2009 to start
doing the Lakers championship rings and
then the last three Warriors
championship rings were able to do as
well these are the last two rings
when you're building a ring for a
championship team you have to make every
one happen each and every player to the
ownership to the fans and you need a
ring that kind of tells the story of the
journey that team went through for that
particular ring this is the 2017 ring
which went down in the championship ring
history as the most amount of diamonds
on any championship ring across the four
major sports we have over an eleven
hundred stones total over 11 carats of
diamonds in 2018 we felt like we needed
to kind of outdo ourselves so we created
this ring some of the players really
like the blue some of the players really
like the white being that it was a
back-to-back championship I thought it
would be a unique thing to have a
reversible top so if you actually see
here this top clicks out you can change
the blue to white put them back in and
there we go
[Music]
so this here is the Dunamis hubris and
this was unique in that it's a forty six
millimeter case it has floating diamonds
on the inside it has eight but get
channel set bezel 18 karat white gold
Swiss made 27 jul 2015 14 days and kind
of like DNA behind our brand and one of
the first things I did when I first
started designing pieces I really really
was enamoured by the way floating
diamonds look when they weren't
inhibited by any metals or set in gold
or anything like that I just love them
free loose floating diamonds I thought
it had tons of brilliance it's in
constant motion and that motion kind of
gives it a little bit more life and it's
kind of over the years than what we've
been known for so over here this is our
signature connected collection and I
truly felt like everyone is connected in
some way I have friends from all walks
of life I have friends that are older
younger from different backgrounds and
different religions I mean I've made it
for myself originally you see I'm
wearing the bracelet here and a lot of
people really really enjoyed it and it's
been one of our bestsellers now what
started the business is me just being
creative and trying to design stuff that
I thought was cool for myself this is
actually my personal set of diamond keys
I created this all 18 karat yellow gold
with flawless white diamonds adorning
the keychain as well as a hook and over
here I could just take my keys and they
basically are uniform they fit each and
every key you have so I could put my
office keys I put my home keys and I
just click them in here and put them on
my pocket this way I could travel in
style I'll tell you what it already is
terrible if you lose your keys but if
you lose your diamond keys that's even
worse I have my own wedding band over
here my wife makes sure that I never
forget it she always wants to make sure
it's on I have a problem of being very
fidgety my kids came home one day with
those fidget spinners I
I couldn't I couldn't get rid of it I
loved it I kept using it so I made my
wedding bed a Pichet spinner where just
it just rotates like this with my
fingers so I sit here all day long and
instead of biting my nails or something
else I'm able to just use my ring as a
therapeutic device this is another
interesting piece that we created it has
an egyptian-themed and it's just
something I was inspired I traveled to
Egypt I came back and on the plane ride
home I started designing different
things and this is our Nefertiti pendant
its Nefertiti and it's got the
hieroglyphics in the back and it's got a
very architectural shape 18 karat gold
flawless white diamonds you have a total
price of 15,000 you know what makes this
piece kind of unique is when I was in
Egypt I was able to get some of the sand
and brought it back and had it
incorporate into the piece so instead of
fluorine ions we have the floating sand
it's something different it's
memorabilia back to when I did my
traveling and whoever wears that kind of
feel that kind of spirit behind it
oftentimes we love to do collaborations
I love collaborating with other
creatives and this one is with Alba
series an artist and a client of mine
for the last ten years we took the
all-knowing painting that he had done
and we kind of created a limited 33
piece collection each and every piece
comes with its own box hand-painted by
obviously or this is dependent and it's
made up of seven different pieces and
you can see it's constructed on the back
with a serial number listing one of 33
or two of 33 flawless white diamonds
going around a little over a carat it's
one of my favorite pieces I love the
colors too the color is what kind of
brings it out over here me and a
gentleman by the name of Chris stamp got
together and we wanted to do a
collaborative effort creating a capsule
collection of jewelry that's not
necessarily something you would wear not
a bracelet not a ring but something that
can be in more of an art piece something
that could be placed on a desk in one of
our pieces that we've done here is a
Lego set
these are all operational labial pieces
18 karat white gold with diamonds all
flawless diamonds over here each and
every one comes in a set it's a limited
production of 50 sets and it's due to
release later on this year something
like this you're looking at around
25,000 yeah
they all click together yeah you can
build your own little robot so this is
our diamond syringe pendant it was also
a collaboration we did with Marcus
Molinari we have a ring as well this is
part of our addictive collection and
it's kind of a play on words has
floating rubies on the center 18 karat
white gold over 2 carats of white
diamonds going around and it's kind of
just a fun fun piece along with other
addictive collection pieces that we've
done we've sold pieces like this to
Rihanna to Katy Perry as perches there's
Lindsay Lohan's purchases so we've had
countless celebrities that actually have
really taken to our creativity everyone
has a vice and it doesn't necessarily
play to the drug aspect it places the
the ideology of addiction whether you
have an addiction to shopping like my
wife to be quite honest with my
addictions always been diamonds my
addictions always being being creative
so this really embodies my creative
spirit this particular collection a lot
of people don't know that the majority
of rubies are more expensive than
diamonds when you get into high quality
rubies and you see the Burmese rubies
and the dark pigeon blood red rubies
you're starting to see Hollywood and the
entertainment is we really embrace that
to just recently sold green emerald ring
to Big Sean and ASAP Rocky we're doing a
whole collection with him a necklace for
him with all different color stones so
they we're getting a lot of clients
requesting that in there you didn't see
that five years ago we're known for a
lot of the over-the-top extravagant
engagement rings and like everyone at
one point or another usually has to pop
that important question will you marry
me and I love being a part of that
process I get to sit down with my plan
and we
to create and design a ring that really
embodies the taste in the identity of
the person he or she is proposing to so
this particular ring here is a 17 carat
stone you're talking about H color vvs1
clarity with all you setting coming all
the way around over here and you're
looking at a price of something like
this is approaching 1 million dollars
when you present a ring you're not
hoping for an out that's for sure we
have a client that had come to us and
wanted to get all one carat BS one GI a
certified white diamonds for a cross and
a necklace 18 karat gold and you're
looking at over $600,000 for this
particular necklace it is truly
something special here just to be able
to source the stones and get every stone
exactly the same color the same diameter
the same millimetre the same clarity and
kind of match them and sort them
together that's a task in itself people
don't understand how much work goes
behind not only designing these pieces
but sourcing them and finding a diamond
like this 30 carat diamond it's not
something you make one call and you get
it it means getting on a plane
it means traveling across the globe it
means going to places maybe you don't
want to go you have to really scour the
earth to find the proper diamond for
your client I have absolutely no idea
when I design something whether or not
it's going to sell and to be quite frank
I really don't care I started making
these crazy pieces just because I could
and it was fun and I didn't think that
anyone else would actually enjoy it
until that first day eight years ago we
opened our store and we had clients
walking in and buying pieces I thought
they would never buy I realized I was
awesome
[Music]